[Music]  how to write your thoughts in a canister  ethiopia has a tradition of handmade  books the first illustrated Bible was  made in Ethiopia 1500 years ago these  new sheets are made from waste paper  saga Kofman and suleiman shiva have  created the social enterprise falak  palak is Amharic for planet and to  reduce the planet's burden of waste  plastic they make covers from canisters  one notebook costs $14 customers include  the African Union Commission the  founders say that with every notebook  purchase they can supply one students  exercise books for an entire school year  do you like that if you are also doing  your bit tell us about it visit our  website or send us a tweet hashtag doing  your bit we share your stories